All of us are trying to get through this
the best that we can
and we're finding
ourselves making decisions
we might not make otherwise.
I understand that you've fostering a dog.
You've been taking care of a
dog temporarily, is that true?
Oh my god, what's his name?
Yes, this is Tommy.
This is Tommy, he's a
little old man. (laughs)
But he is the sweetest dog ever.
You know, I'm home all the time now.
Usually I'm working and traveling,
and I can't take care of dog.
But, yeah, I had a friend reach out.
I was not planning on
having a dog that day
and then the next thing
I know I got this guy.
So if you go to @wagmor,
if anybody's interested
in adopting little Tommy,
I'm gonna have until he
finds a forever home.
But, I mean, look at this.
Look at this face!
Oh, look at that guy!
(Evan laughs)
You know what, I have to say,
he doesn't look thrilled to be seeing me.
(Evan laughs)
His face kind of fell like, "oh, that one.
That host, huh, all right, okay."
So, I wanna get the word out,
because if someone's out there
who would love a sweet, older...
Let's just say mature dog.
A mature dog.
He's mature, yes.
And it's @wagmor?
Mm-hmm, wagmor, just M-O-R, yeah.
Yeah, he's a sweetie and
he's very low maintenance.
He doesn't do a whole lot now,
except just wanna be
cuddled, and fed, and yeah.
So if anybody wants
little Tommy, he's here.
Yeah, I'm telling you,
as someone who's quite
a bit older than you,
that happens later on.
Yeah (laughs).
I wanna be cuddled, I wanna be held,
occasionally dragged onto the porch
to take care of whatever
I have to take care of,
and then dragged back in again.
That's exactly right.
That's pretty much my life.